>> Mark: HE WAS HERE AS AN HIS
OTTAWA SENATOR ON UP.
THOMSON THROUGH THE
NOW A CENTRING PASS.
>> PLAYS
GOES RIGHT BACK.
AND HE WILL HANG ON. L-TIME LEA
NORRIS SHOOTS FROM A
THE Gord: OF IMPORTANT
PLAYERS AS WELL.
>> Gord: GOES BACK, DANAULT.
YOU GIVE HIM A LITTLE YEARS IN
LSO I IMAGINE.
NOT FEELING WELL, IT'S LAST MIN
PLAY.
GUY.
>> APPARENTLY.
NO NIGHT IN ALL
>> FROM THE NEW YORK AREA LAYER
>> THE BETTER OFF OTTAWA WILL
HE'S TRACKING THE PUCK AND HE'S
>> EDLER ACROSS TO
TERRIBLE TIM
EDLER AND THE KINGS.
-- BACK TO KE
BRINGS IT BACK AROUND, KOPITAR
WAITING FOR IT. STICK.
WHEN YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO PLAY
ON THE PUCK YOU HAVE TO MAKE IT
COUNT.
TKACHUK INTO IT.
>> SAME WAY ENNIS. OTING IT.
ELECTING NOT TO SCORE IT.
HE'S GOT A GOOD CH AS TIERNEY
BY DEL
NORRIS.
BACK HE GOES TO CHABOT.
35S DANAULT. PLE EXTRA LOOKS AN
JUST NOT ABLE TO